ce dix mois et dit ouais t'as gagné
beaucoup d'argent dans ta vie quand même
non ouais mais j'espère que ça va
continuer parce qu'on a toujours besoin
d'un réfectoire vous ont le feu comme
tout le monde
si la dépense et abat oui c'est fait
pour ça donc du point
je n'ai pas inventé le système tu
pourrais arrêter la tête soit arrêté ah
non tu peux pas t'arrêter un nom fera ni
non comment mais je crois qu'ils avaient
de l'argent à gauche moi même souffle à
droite si tu cela au mieux c'est bien tu
prends quand même pour un cinéma
millions non voilà un peu près oui du
coup bon pour bien débuter ouais hein
dis ça ne rapporte combien vous qui
marche
ouais tu parlais une époque de 3
millions
non ça 3 millions c'est pour fonctionner
ce différend pour pouvoir payer les
impôts ah ouais il faut 3 millions par
an comme pour repayer tout le monde
une fois que tu as fait des impôts et 13
points mais on s'est tu ben non non non
il faut que j'y retourne à fait d'accord
c'est dur c'est très dur là va nous
tirer les larmes qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont plus haut et pourquoi tu
en parles pas ton ami cher à 7 ans
mais là rien à voir oui mais je sais pas
taxer autant les artistes utiliserait
une passe à un peu mon nom michel fait
son métier je fais le mur ne tue a dit
l'état est le plus grand macro de la
terre lui à 10h à wil de son mobile
normal attention comme je lui dis par
contre je suis peut-être
une fille de rue mais je ne donne pas le
corps je suis fière du casino aussi
qu'ils ont coûté du pognon fini tu t'es
fait interdire on était tranquille un
comble peu en vue et entendu parler de
la nouvelle idée de ton ami chasse
non je crois moi tu prends tout mais on
parle pas de cela on impose sur l'impôt
c'est à dire c'est de l'info de l'intox
et un avis un impôt sur l'impôt un as tu
me connais bien non c passable même
peut-être que ça peut ni d'être une idée
de dieu savoir l on va regarder